all right so we have made Lucille and
now we're going to test her out and
we're going to use Internet with the
help of my zombie friends here who
helped me and shoot my zombie apocalypse
fishing video and we're going to do a
shot of the dead versus walking dead
situation here we've got a cricket bat
which straight from Bangalore India here
and we've got our Lucille and we are
going to smash a load of crap with both
of these and we really like to know
which one is better
Oh ready come on go for it all right go
for it all right I'll smash your heart
Oh what's your thoughts how do you feel
I like to have I think for a brain smash
I mean it would be everywhere awesome
yes you guys you guys smell it awesome
okay go for it
Oh let's go cracker
whoa good clean kill not about the best
it's about the plan okay ready yeah oh
that just pull right yo clean up oh my
good
[Applause]
we're calling oh look at that like Ted
Nugent you lose it I'll be all right
with that
Oh Daisy no it would be a few were three
well what's this guy's name
um I call him Chowdhury Chowdhury
sweetie you didn't kill this guy yeah
thank you go for it
let's see huh one more yeah I get it
follow up roll it up is this figure back
is good eat like I don't know yes that's
it all right there we go
Hey down there ready snip super now go
for it
please going down there all right okay
okay I'm sorry laughing Wow only that
hey not happening and what allowed me
just good for spreading zombie bits
around that's for sure oh okay we need
to do this lesson alright go for all of
that here six full force oh oh wait so
that's our lesson I'm Mike
oh yeah yeah all right guys so what do
you think was that fun
so what do you say cricket versus Lupino
cricket bad versus lucilda my stereo
feel pretty good I guess
you know I think the cricket bat like
hatches more brute force but this is
like a smaller area and you get that
little insult to injury the barb so do
you think that a more force but it's a
broader area raise your hands if you
think the cricket bat is better for
special zombie head I'm not gonna do
that
hey deal yeah actually I don't know I'm
like a girl it's like Chinese which we
know which one you love more you can't
say no I will say that I think this will
probably be more durable you know like
you know you get a bo Jackson hit on
someone's head you might snap that in
the middle of a zombie fight and that
would be a big deal this thing is not
never going to break I mean it is a
little bad yeah that might get stuck in
the skull that's an excellent point
that's an excellent point in doing that
but you get a metal bag and I wrap on a
little bit of that a little bit of that
with that well you have to like welded
or something that would be interesting
yeah thanks for watching and hopefully
you enjoyed this so in case of a zombie
apocalypse leave a comment let us know
how our reviews helped you and you want
to see more videos like this please
click subscribe thanks for watching